My office.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
I want you to imagine something with me.
Imagine
that you die.
And when you die, the veil of this dunya
and its illusion is lifted.
If you want to say what is
the overwhelming feeling that is
unanimous across the board, every human
being will feel it. Whether they are
Muslim or non-Muslim, believer or
disbeliever,
old or young, male or female, wealthy or
poor.
What will they all feel at the moment of
death?
They will all come to the
crashing realization of just how petty,
small, and insignificant this world is.
That is the unanimous realization that
everyone will have. The great awakening,
the dunya will get so tiny and so small
that it will be a faint forgotten
dream,
a faded memory.
And the hereafter will be so clear, so
visceral,
so incredibly vivid,
you will think to yourself, "How could I
ever have overlooked this?"
Now imagine you're in that situation
and
you got a chance
after realizing
the reality of this life, the reality of
the next life
and you reach that point where Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
Hadid
that at the moment of death the veil is
removed from the eyes. What is the veil?
It is the illusion of this dunya, right?
The beckoning, the I promise. Just come
with me. I promise. I promise this is
going to be great. I promise. I It's
just around the next corner. I've been
following you for 50 years. No, no, no.
You You're almost there. Next corner.
Right around the next corner. It's right
there. Right around the next corner.
Just 10 more steps. Just one more year.
Just six more months.
And then once you get there, you're
going to rest and you're going to make
everything correct at the end. That's
what we're all told, right? And then you
reach that position where the veil is
lifted. You see just how cheap this
world really is.
and the veil is lifted and your sight is
2020. At that moment,
your sight is steel.
What would be the thing at that moment
you would wish for?
What would we all wish for at that
moment?
Obviously,
hassanet, right? Good deeds. That's what
we would wish for. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says,
[Silence]
That's what everybody wishes for.
That's what we would all wish for. But
then you realize that that is permanent.
This was temporary and there is nothing
you can do to change it. Not even the
[Arabic recitation]
sallall.aii wasallam, not even if all of
the prophets and messengers collaborated
to intercede on your behalf.
If Allah does not accept that
intercession, it equals nothing for you.
So you're in that position. What is the
thing you wish for the most? Even one
good deed. Because at the end of the
day, when we take a precise scale that
has two sides to it, and we put things
on this side and things on this side,
if it is very precise, what will tip the
scale in one of the two
ends is one. It is just one. One good
deed. That's what will enter you into
paradise.
And it is just one bad deed that will
admit someone into the hellfire. One,
just one. Imagine how desperate you
would be at that point.
Now imagine that somehow you could
actually
do good deeds but after your death
and you can reap the rewards of those
good deeds in real time.
Well, our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
tells us that that that is actually
possible.
narrates that our messenger
said
[Silence]
the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam said if
the human being dies all of his deeds
come to a halt
except three types of deeds which
continue after his death beyond the
grave.
a continuous charity
or knowledge which is of consequence,
beneficial knowledge
or a righteous child that will continue
to pray on his behalf.
This is the only three things that will
continue past that transition of death.
So right now, right now there are three
types of people that are receiving
rewards in their grave. Right now
those who have given charity and that
charity is continuous. It continues to
move on and roll on and so it is
continuously beneficial. So they
continue to reap the rewards of that.
But let me ask you, how long
can a
continuous charity last?
Best case scenario, how long?
[Arabic recitation]
say you build a masjid. How long can
that masid last on earth?
[Arabic recitation]
It had to be rebuilt many times.
Eventually,
it's going to come to an end, right?
Or a righteous child. How long is your
child going to last? A lifetime.
Maybe if he teaches his children, maybe
a few generations. Sure.
What about
knowledge?
Beneficial knowledge.
Knowledge of the worship of Allah.
knowledge of Allah's names and
attributes.
Can you imagine
that if I sit here on this chair and I
say one thing that touches your hearts
and you all go in your separate ways and
that has an effect on your deeds, you
implement it, your children pick it up,
people around you pick it up. Every
single moment that that knowledge is put
into action, it comes right back into my
into my good deeds. And every word I
have ever uttered goes right back into
my teacher's good deeds. All of it. And
that continues all the way back to our
messenger Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam.
If you can even imagine how much reward
that is. But right but beneficial
knowledge is the only thing that will
last until Allah takes back the Quran.
Until Allah takes back the earth and all
that is in it.
Charity, yes. Righteous children, yes.
But the thing that has the greatest
longevity and lifespan on this earth is
righteous knowledge. things that people
will not cease to implement even when
they move on to the next life.
And Abu also narrates that a man is
sitting in his grave
and suddenly his
level of bliss is elevated in his grave
and he says to Allah,
Why was my level of pleasure suddenly
increased? He says,
he says, "Your son that's still alive,
he just made dua for you right now."
So we see that these things are
connecting. They are working when in
real time right now, this moment. And
that's what's beautiful about our
creator Allah. Subhanahu wa ta'ala. He
doesn't wait to reward us until the end.
He interacts with us in real time. Every
verse of the Quran we recite, he
answers. Every dua we make, he responds.
Every good deed we do, he implements his
pleasure upon us right now in real time.
Your life is not you want it to be.
You can start changing it right now.
tonight, right now, this minute.
This minute. And the key to all of that
is knowledge of the Quran and Sunnah.
And because of this, is there any price
that we can ever reach to repay our
scholars. Let's say you go to paradise
and you remember she Ali taught me the
narration or the verse. And I'm here
right now because my scales tipped in my
direction of paradise because of that
one good deed that I happen to hear from
Sheikh Ali. Here I am in paradise. Can
you repay me for that? Tell me what
amount what dollar amount can you put on
that to repay me?
What dollar amount can I put to repay
one of my teachers?
You cannot repay me no more than I can
repay my teachers. No more than we can
repay our prophet Sam. Wasam. It's
impossible. This knowledge is priceless.
Money is too cheap for this knowledge.
This knowledge demands your very heart
and soul. That's the only way you get
it. Money you can't pay for it. It's not
for sale.
[Silence]
, please go to my office, grab some
water bottles and put them here so I can
a general